[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
VIC GUNDOTRA: To the over 6,000
people here, to our
Google I/O viewing parties that
are happening all around
the world, to the over 1 million
people who will be
watching live stream on YouTube,
welcome to Google
I/O.
HUGO BARRA: It's been
pretty busy here.
And I'm thrilled to announce
our latest milestone.
1 million new Android devices
are activated
every single day.
[CHEERING]
HUGO BARRA: We're introducing
Nexus 7.
It's a beautiful, seven-inch
tablet.
It's running Android
4.1 Jelly Bean.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOE BRITT: We brought together
the power of Android and
Google Play to develop the first
consumer electronics
product Google has ever
designed and built
from the ground up.
We call it Nexus Q.
MALE SPEAKER: Like, even the
ports are high quality.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm a huge geek.
This is my Christmas.
MALE SPEAKER: There's a lot of
cool things that have come out
on the Chrome side pretty that
I'm pretty excited about.
SUNDAR PICHAI: It's an exciting
demo to see Chrome on
Android phones, Android tablets,
and now on the iPhone
and the iPad.
So no matter which device you're
using, we are working
really hard, across all
important software platforms.
No other browser vendor
is doing this.
And as of today, we've almost
doubled again to 310 million
active users.
By our internal metrics, Chrome
is the most popular
browser in the world globally.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUBREY ANDERSON: Cirque du
Soleil in a browser.
What a fantastic challenge.
We created this world
completely in HTML.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
URS HOLZLE: This is what happens
when you add 10,000
cores to your application.
That's the kind of scalability
and performance that Google
can deliver.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: In just one year,
over 250 million people
have upgraded to Google+.
The life we plan, we party,
we keep in touch, we think
software should make all
of that more awesome.
That's why today we are so
excited to be announcing
Google+ Events.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm always
surprised by the capability of
developers to party.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
MALE SPEAKER: Over 1,000 people
turned on party mode,
and contributed over 13,700
photographs from
last night's concert.
PATRICK MONAHAN: Google,
its as big as it gets.
And it's as cool as it gets.
SERGEY BRIN: Who wants to see
a demo [? of  Boss. ?]
MALE SPEAKER: And they're off.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]
MALE SPEAKER: There's only
one good way down
the side of a building.
Don't run anybody over.
MALE SPEAKER: When they jumped
out of the blimp onto the
Moscone Center, and they
rappelled off the side and
biked it in, that was the most
exciting thing I saw.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: This, ladies and
gentleman, truly is the best
time ever to deliver, and
to build for the web.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: It's just the love
that Google gives back to
their developers.
SERGEY BRIN: Thank you
all very much.